ces faits qu'il avait demandé regarder
j'en étais toi est ce que tu comptes
faire une énorme émission fiesta enfin
d'arc à fond en prime après le
confinement à bala je t'explique là
après le confinement
il ya très peu de chances que je rende
l'antenne avant avant deux heures du
matin là ça va être fait doux explique
la c8 il le savoir l'âge tu expliques tu
vas près tous les danseurs qui ont dansé
dans tpm paix depuis la création
moi je leur sera certainement le retour
de l'animal je voudrais vous dire déjà
je voulais vous faire un gros bisou vous
dire que je vous aime vous remercier
pour tous les messages que vous me
laissez sur les réseaux sociaux partout
voilà et je voulais vous dire que
vraiment vraiment vraiment on pense à
vous on vous lâche pas vous ne m'avez
jamais lâché et je vois pas pourquoi je
vous laisserai ya plein de gens qui me
disent ouais merci cyril est là merci
syrie d'être là franchement c'est normal
si je n'avais pas été là je m'en serais
voulu et on voit là vous êtes en
confinement et vous pouvez faire venir
chez vous pour 24 heures il n'a pas le
corps d'un virus il est clair net la
meuf aussi voilà vous pouvez faire venir
quelqu'un chez vous alors laurent
trilles sais qui tu fais venir clichés
doit dit la vérité avait dit la vérité
on se dit la vérité ce soir allez vas-y
non c'est pas vrai bon très bon je viens
alors qu'elle a un match que tu t'étais
livrés c'était vraiment tous été
reconnus dans ton témoignage qu'il ya
plein de gens qui m'ont dit c'est vrai
que moi je me rends compte pendant ce
confinement que j'ai parfois été voilà
il ya des gens que je vois plus alors je
me dis tu vois si je pensais pas que ça
pouvait arriver ça et que si demain je
devais plus revoir une personne avec qui
je suis un petit peu effritée bas c'est
vrai que ça me ferait de la peine
toi pour le coup c'est ton papa donc
c'est quelqu'un de très très proches sur
mon père bien évidemment pour l'instant
c'est compliqué charles est suffisament
se voit on peut pas bouger
j'ai eu des nouvelles par des gens de la
famille donc je sais qu'il est confiné
aussi que le temps passe qui vieillit et
que et que je je pense qu'en tout cas ça
fait beaucoup réfléchir à travailler
vite faire un pas pour pour y aller
sarah thermique peut-être des nettoyer
un peu quelque chose qui se nettoyer pas
c'est quand tu t'arrêtes pas finalement
que tu continues tu avis bas
voilà mathieu on espère en tout cas que
ça va s'arranger que tu seras voilà que
ton papa je suis sûr qu'il doit être
comme un fou mecheri merci d'être avec
nous et oui c'est un halo baba c'est
spécial ce soir puisque c'est les dix
ans deux pb mt alors il était une fois
été pmp et oui 1er avril un vous
rappeler de ce 1er avril
alors je vous racontais on avait démarré
sur france 4 c'est vrai que au départ
j'avais fait un grand casting de
chroniqueurs j'avais été voir france
télévisions france télévisions je
faisais fa si la chanter à l'époque et
je savais que fa si la chanter ça
n'allait pas durer très longtemps donc
tu allais voir bruno gaston qui était le
directeur d'épreuve de l'époque et
nicolas pernikoff qu'on a on a la chance
qui travaillent avec nous je leur ai dit
voilà je voudrais faire une émission sur
les médias
voilà donc qui regardent la télé c'est à
dire la télé qui regardent la télé et on
ferait l'émission voilà on donnerait
notre avis comme ça avec des
spécialistes merci d'être là qu'est dit
elle avec elle avec ça se tape somme
toute si shia j'ambitionne merck est là
qui nous a rejoint aussi vous nous
demandiez beaucoup de nouvelles de
crédit et de jean michel mr et ben voila
vous les envoyer il y en a une qui a
l'air plus en forme que l'autre a ouai
enfin oui non mais voilà en tout cas
voilà qui est dit a l'air plus avant je
sais pas si c'est la lumière ou sais pas
ce que c'est elle approuve un peu toi
mon envie d'amour nous aussi alors
jean-michel mon chéri merci d'être là
est ce que tu vas venir déjà parce que
c'est un petit peu malade oui oui non ça
va très bien parce que j'ai eu et j'ai
tous les symptômes du corona mais je
sais plus vraiment parce qu'au moment
gelé où je pense l'avoir eu sous chinois
avaient très fortement déplu chez moi au
super il m'a dit que j'avais toutes mes
chances à tous les mois les choses si on
peut dire entre guillemets de la voie à
ce que j'avais tous les symptômes sauce
une grille ce qu une grippe et une
pierre ou qui étaient pas important un
coton tout ça tu veux que je te dise
comment ai vu qu avant tu es en forme au
niveau de l'élocution je pense que tout
va bien
c'est parti ces partis benjamin castaldi
c'est 1000 euros pour les hôpitaux c'est
très petit benjamin normes et attendant
non mais t'es pense lits plats on te
voit pas aller moi c'est tout
mais moi je bosse c'est quoi ce slip là
à l'évasion commence à 20h irie savarino
est pourquoi qu'elle n' aura elles ont
l'air plus en forme que les autres
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont des têtes celle où
kelly et nos races et les deux seuls qui
sont fraîches sur la tête de la ville
regarde les autres à tous des têtes donc
normal non mais sans rigoler c'est bien
peu choquerait tu vois c'est quand même
les dix ans est ce que tu te rappelles
hainaut de tout recrutement commente
avaient été recrutés dans tpm putois
avant j'étais payé non j'y donnais
clauzel dont je crois pas donné de l'eau
et non moi je me rappelle juste avait vu
dans une émission
ouais et et j'avais dit j'avais appelé
je me rappelle la produit le producteur
de l'émission j'avais dit il nourrir
faut absolument c'est elle qui nous
manque dont l'émission est de tumaco la
laitue 1 0 je ressemblais à turco belle
vraiment regarder qui nous a rejoint il
ya big flo et oli
il ya des jours où ça va te faire au
maire ces détails à m sila donc à franck
gastambide qui encore line et qui peut
placer que vous aurez la tournée mission
là on dirait les gens vous voient ils
font à qui je suis sûr que les
téléspectateurs os x qui la télé là on a
télé là où vous êtes à la télé gala
entre héros thomas pesquet vas-y way
phoque dans la date de la saison 2
j'aimerais bien que d'abord d'abord la
saison de l ai écrit donc là j'attends
plus que l'on sortira chez nous à
l'écrit de franck tu sais pas parler ou
quoi franck
[Rires]
troc est ce que je serai dans la saison
2 un petit passage quand même comme dans
la première que tout ce que tu veux même
plusieurs passages situés
merci mon frère ahmed qui lâche mia un
humoriste franchement je dis la vérité
aux autres ce soir c'est la vérité c'est
les dix ans de la vérité on s'emballe il
y en a un
très honnêtement il ne fait pas rire
ouais vraiment une fée paris et
humainement humains demande franchement
c'est une merde
gad elmaleh sans la gombe la réponse si
on n'accepte pas de réponse non acceptés
franck s'il avait dit elie on tire est
ce que tu peux nous faire une petite
blague
bah oui c'est une blague pourrie un bien
évidemment ça se passe dans un bar
willaya il ya un policier qui rentre
dans le bureau du commissaire et qui dit
cherchait il ya un braquage de la
supérette
on a volé 5 kg de carottes et des
cartouches de cigarettes et le
commissaire répond et vous avez un
suspect et oui on recherche un lapin qui
touche j'ai percuté le cadre du théma
gagner des millions elle embrasse
également je sais bull en bresse mots
jean pierre merci d'être avec nous ce
qu'on joue pour les hôpitaux de paris
hôpitaux de france
on joue ici à qui veut gagner des
millions parce que les millions on n'en
a pas on joue avec nabila tu peut saluer
nabila qui est très heureux de t'avoir
au téléphone la question la voici
jean pierre tu as 30 secondes pour
répondre parce qu'on a moins de temps
que sur tf1
quelle ville rendue célèbre par raphaël
mezrahi se trouve dans le département
numéro 10 trois sets
mon cul ou dreux nabila jean-pierre tenu
3 est-ce que tu suis jean pierre
foucault haut bas bas forcément je suis
né je suis les yeux fermés jean pierre
foucault rapportent les 10000 euros
dinars pour les hôpitaux de paris
hôpitaux de france
bravo labida on de grâce à nabila aux
hôpitaux de paris hôpitaux de france
voilà grâce à nabila et voilà c'est ce
soir chez ba ba oui la bio je voyage
c'est claude commun on voulait rajouter
quelque chose on aimerait qu'on aimerait
donner la même somme aussi aux acheteurs
de france
non je vous aime très fort les deux ont
fait ce qu'il fallait et cyril tahon pas
te marrer what the fuck wayuu la chine
semble bien parce qu'un pilote est
atteint c'est a tenu cette à tenue qui
me dérange un peu mine de rien c'est
vrai que j'ai rarement fait des
interviews avec des gens avec une tenue
pas et je te dis la vérité j'ai c'est la
première fois
vraiment c'est j'aie jamais faits à
balances ton poste avec le khalife qui
vient habiller comme ça mais bon c'est
pas grave c'est aussi serré cyril tu dis
là avec un twin otter moi je suis unique
a comme les autres